bonsoir monsieur ajouté vous avez
beaucoup vous êtes beaucoup exprimé sur
cet enjeu là êtes vous soulagé
de cette étape entre de ce qui est
annoncé aujourd'hui plus soulagé que
réjouis parce qu'il reste encore
beaucoup de choses à faire il ya encore
beaucoup d'incertitudes dans ce projet
là mais on a évité le pays du moins pour
le tronçon centre-ville
parce que ce ton soleil était absolument
inacceptable et pas juste en termes de
design au plan financier le premier
ministre avoue lui-même quand on retire
ce tronçon là c'est la viabilité de tout
projet qui est en cause et ccq pourquoi
les caisses ce métier et ça ça veut dire
que le projet s'était d'abord et avant
tout un projet d'investissement c'est un
retour sur l'investissement qu'on
anticipait il s'était pas un projet de
transport et bon j'ai écouté le
qui dit j'espère qu'on fera pas un
projet strictement de transport à
l'ancienne c'est exactement ce qu'on
nous propose est avec cp 10 qui fera un
projet de transport à l'ancienne pour
ali mais au territoire à paris mais au
besoin d'aucune manière et donc de ce
point de vue je pense que la pause
actuelle vont être très salutaire la
caisse voulait un projet rentable
achalandés on demande à la caisse faites
nous un projet développé un projet la
caisse doit développer le meilleur
projet le plus rentable mais est ce
qu'on comprend qu'il ne développe pas
nécessairement le meilleur projet qui
répond à tous les besoins qu'on
identifie dans l'est effectivement
d'ailleurs la grèce s'en est jamais
caché dès le début ils ont dit nous
planifions pas du transport nous n'avons
pas d' expertise ce n'est pas notre
mission on lui demande de faire un
projet en nous garantissant rendement
nous faisons projet qui nous garantit un
rendement et la nature du projet défini
en fonction de cet objectif là aidé à
partir de ces choses pour l'europe de
l'ouest c'est la même chose que les
rênes des lois ça va être la même chose
si on poursuit avec les rem sur la
rive-sud si on en est maintenant à laval
c'est un modèle d'affaires qu'on voulait
exporter et ça c'est assez clair que
c'était une des intentions ça dit que
montréal est un banc d'essai pourrait
lui porter éventuellement on le voit
bien que ce genre de projet là ne peut
être rentable que dans certaines
conditions par exemple certaines villes
en asie avec des densités
mais très étendue peut-être que le sert
à terme on voit bien qu'ils sont
montréal ont tout juste crayon marchés
fictifs le gouvernement est obligé d'un
gt d'ageas année après année on demande
aux municipalités qu'on peut voir
chapitre d'injecter de l'argent année
après année et ont pigé dans les
clientèles des autres réseaux pour créer
une rentabilité cette fiction sera celle
conclue est-ce donc l'échec de ce modèle
là parce que quand même le rem de
l'ouest locke key qui va entrer en
service qui qui on approche de l'arrivée
du rem de l'ouest est-ce que c'est
l'échec de ce modèle là ou si simplement
qu'ils avaient pas d'acceptabilité
sociale c'était c'était trop flagrant
comme projet dans le décor des citoyens
c'est à dire l'absence d'accès
d'acceptabilité sociale a obligé de
révéler l'échec du modèle parce qu'à
partir du moment où on nous dit ce
tronçon là si nous ne l'avons pas nous
leur tirons nous retirons nos b on voit
bien que la priorité c'était le retour
sur investissement est donc le fait
qu'il ya eu beaucoup d'oppositions qui a
eu des oppositions sur le secteur du
centre ville et des oppositions sur
d'autres secteurs mais j'appelle aussi
que beaucoup d'oppositions sur les
modalités de la gouvernance sur la
manière dont on finance le projet parce
que dans l'ouest rien de réglé quand les
maires des municipalités vont recevoir
la facture ils vont demander chanter
c'est le modèle de gouvernance aussi
c'est pas juste le tracé c'est pas juste
le design c'est pas juste de recouper
finalement des lignes la ligne verte la
ligne bleue le srb pie-ix ses modèles de
gouvernance que vous remettez aussi en
question pour l'europe de l'ouest comme
pour les autres potentiels sauf qu'à la
nuance que dans le cas de john de
l'ouest on a approprié un commandant
ferroviaire passager qui était très très
efficace donc on doit simplement mis la
main sur un actif et ça permet
évidemment de développer dans athènes
vers le west island mais là dans les
sondés dans une conjoncture complètement
différente hélas le modèle évidemment
tant qu'au moins pertinent qu'il ne
l'était dans l'ouest en même temps vous
savez vous où vous connaissez vous
suivez le l'urbanisme transport depuis
longtemps les projets sont difficiles à
développer puis des fois ça prend une
éternité puis il ya des sujets ou des
lignes bleues dont on entend parler
pendant des décennies la caisse fait
fonctionner des projets le rem de
l'ouest là c'est allé vite est-ce qu'on
n'a pas besoin de projets qui marchent
et qui marche rapidement compte tenu des
besoins que nous avons oui on a besoin
de projets qui marchent effectivement la
caisse tourner rondement mais il ya
quand même des retards ça dès qu'on
n'est pas sur les échéanciers on n'est
pas sur les coûts prévus à l'origine
donc même quand on a quand on a les
coudées aussi farouche que la cresse
levée on n'est pas capable de garantir
l'échéancier et les coûts du projet
évidemment sûr multiplier le nombre
d'acteurs ça se complique mais il faut
quand même revenir à une chose qui est
fondamental le problème du transport
collectif dans la région métropolitaine
de montréal c'est le problème qui est
générée par l'attitude du gouvernement
du québec depuis des années et des
années où sa très belle la ligne bleue
qui est le plus bel exemple est encore
récemment on nous dit le premier
ministre nous dit la ligne bleue elle va
se faire dans les livres comptables du
grandement les budgets pour la
réalisation ne sont au chaud pendant que
ce soit encore des budgets de
planification dont on ne sait pas encore
la sauce dans le collet dingli alors
qu'est ce qui va se passer qu'est ce qui
doit se passer parce que l'europe de
l'est existe encore et le tracé est à
peu près semblable on parle d'aller vers
lanaudière ou vers l'aval qu'est ce qui
va se passer avec la suite des choses
selon vous mais moi je pense que des
choses qui va se passer assez rapidement
compte tenu que l'omerta élevé avec la
nouvelle gouvernance il ya des choses
qui vont apparaître sur la table qui
vont nous permettre de déterminer dans
quelle mesure est ce que c'est cette
solution de quilles et la plus les plus
intéressants parce que pour l'instant
tout ce qu'on a c'est un a priori qu'un
très léger automatisé en aérien ou
optionnelle c'est la solution pour
l'instant ça n'a jamais été validé par
personne mais l'on reporte aux calendes
grecques la pas nécessairement se dit
que si on a vraiment de volonté d'y
aller le politique au lieu de s'ingérer
dans les détails devrais-je devra porter
le projet et forcer les organistes
convention autour d'une table a donné
des résultats et ça je pense qu'on peut
y arriver d'autant que la rtm ont une
preuve adonis a dit qu'ils ont été
passablement brasse et au cours des
derniers mois je pense qu'ils ont à mon
unique effectivement ils sont capables
de répondre à l'émission qu'on leur
accorde ayant été complètement
renversées du projet laisse même gérard
beaudet merci beaucoup c'est très classe
merci bien
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici r d